[Music]
this is an updated version of the build
I created just before taking a six-month
break from the division after the
release of 1.7 I jumped into the game
with my old PvE build already equipped
so I decided to try it out and see if it
was still relevant with a few tweaks I
can honestly say that in my opinion this
is still the best easiest build for
taking on the PvE content in the
division I'm not claiming this is the
fastest build the clearing content and
when it comes to pc players there's a
few other options out there but when
you're on console and your aim is as
inconsistent as mine this build will
help clear even the most difficult PvE
content in the game I've used this with
challenging missions underground light
zone farming incursions and even soloing
legendary missions much like in 1.6
stacking towards skill power is the way
to go sure dispelled you're a little bit
squishy and your DPS in a little bit low
but that's okay cuz your skills are
doing most of the damage for you when it
comes to the most difficult PvE content
the difference between 500k toughness
and 300k toughness is a fraction of a
second when under heavy NPC fire why not
deploy something to be doing slash
taking the damage for you while you sit
safely at the distance as with all of my
builds videos I'll be trying to keep
this as clear and concise as possible I
will never state that you need to match
everything I've added to the build and
instead the idea is for you to use this
as a starting point or a template for
your own build change things up and
personalize it for your style play this
build consists of four piece by quest
and two piece technicians as I said
earlier the idea is to have your skills
doing and taking most of the damage
however with the right talents you'll be
able to do a decent amount of damage
with your weapons too as long as you
keep a little distance between yourself
in the enemy all gear pieces have been
rolled into skill power and all major
attributes skill power or skill haste
first or to help the Commuter of these
are available all mods should be
electronics with a skill haste as the
attribute applying the above should
leave you with around
8900 electronics and 45 to 50% skill
haste the equipped skills are flame
turrets and air both seeker Minds if
seeker mines have had a big nerf in 1.7
but they're still extremely useful in
hunting down in exposing hidden enemies
and slowing down shotgun rushes the bulk
of your skill damage will
coming from the turret however the key
to this build is via both the turret and
seeker mind will ignite enemies and by
using the following talents you'll
ensure that most enemies in front of you
will be on fires and majority of the
time the two talents I would call a must
are wild fire to have the vice bridge
more targets and tech support to keep
your turret active for longer the other
two slots are optional
here I'm using critical safe and steady
hands but in a team situation you may
want Combat Medic the primary weapon I'm
using is the urban India this weapon
synergizes so well with this build
because of the india's unique talent
distracted your damage is increased by
18 percent against targets with status
affects everything you're doing with
this builds causes fire status effects
so you actually end up getting a decent
amount of damage out of this weapon even
with nothing put into firearms the MDR
can be a bit of a pain to get used to on
console and it certainly isn't required
in order to have the cells work but
whatever you'd use I'd recommend rolling
talented onto the weapon although this
talent specifically says that killing a
target with this weapon increases skill
power by 15% for 20 seconds your skills
will also progress talent so as long as
you have a turret out this talent will
be permanently active the secondary
weapon has two purposes one is for range
as you want to be sitting back from the
fight and the other for healing here I
have the m700 the talents include
talented again and predatory this is
your primary way of healing but this
build
much like talent if you don't need to be
shooting the enemies to prop us if your
turret and seeker mines are getting
kills you'll be healing at the end of
this video I've included a cheat sheet
or quick reference guide that sums up
this build and everything I've covered
check it out and see what you think if
this has seemed a little bit complex or
you don't have a lot of the gear
mentioned in this video check out a
video my mate
average ant is released he'll be showing
you a build more directed at the casual
player it may not get you quite the same
stats but it'll certainly help you keep
up with the big boys in the in-game
content a link to the video should be on
screen right now but this channel will
also be included in this description
below I'll leave you with a little bit
of gameplay right now but if you'd like
to see more of this type of content from
us subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment below thanks
keep your heads down and keep it quiet
moaning hostiles detected the escort
party is taking heavy fire from the roof
another shot is you just do it
[Music]
make a bet like you
damn it oh my god
morning additional hospital team coming
[Music]
and
good morning additional hostile team
coming you want to are to back
[Music]
got the medic stink way across candle
and all staff accounted for no
casualties
[Music]